to emily shang emily walk us through
what we're about to see in about four or
five minutes time and then from there
the next 25 minutes or so
all right john four or five minutes time
and when the countdown clock gets to
zero you still got seven more
seconds before actual liftoff but that
is when the engines will light
the rocket will shoot up vertically in
the air about two and a half minutes in
there will be separation the crew
capsule
will separate from the booster they will
both continue on past
the karman line the crew capsule will go
uh higher
than the booster itself that is when
they will experience that weightlessness
for three to four minutes they'll be
told to buckle back up with a 30 second
warning
and they will make their way back down
they will be descending
via parachute so we are looking for full
inflation
with those parachutes once they land and
by the rate the
the booster will land on a landing pad
in a specific location
the crew capsule will land somewhere in
the area now they
they know where they think it's going to
land they have a bunch of vehicles i
believe it's those rivien trucks
stationed on a grid pattern and they are
all ready to
zoom in to retrieve uh jeff bezos and
his crew
as soon as that landing happens we are
taking bets on who will emerge first
i think jeff bezos is going to be the
first to open that hatch uh but but john
and tom i'm curious
uh who you expect to see first well i
always see mrs funk ladies first uh
uh to actually that's the polite thing
to do it was jeff bezos who was the
first
in the capsule i think so maybe he'll be
the first to exit too john at t-minus
two minutes and plus
uh here i think it's important as mr
stenovic mentioned
we have wind in van horn and as emily
mentioned
there are three parachutes out in the
oceans
of cape canaveral and cape kennedy this
was always a very
serious issue depending on where the
astronauts came down in the water it
could be distant from an
aircraft carrier tom we talked about
this a little bit earlier let's do it
again because i always find this part
the most fascinating
we're at t minus two now then after the
launch we get the booster and the
capsule
and they separate and they separated
about 76 kilometers
altitude the capsule is going to go to
about 106 kilometers that's where
they'll experience
that zero gravity they'll unstrap
they'll take in the curvature of the
earth but that separation tom
and the booster returning to earth that
is quite something to see
yeah it's going to be something to see
and then again you're going to see two
images up folks going up only 62
miles i would hope that we will have
camera images
of not only the booster and the
separated capsule at the same time
and then the return of the rocket which
john you and i mentioned we're still not
used to so eight minutes
after the launch tom the reusable new
shepherd booster should land and i
understand we should get some pictures
of that
and we'll do our best to bring them to
you and then 11 minutes after the end
after that time the crew capsule
lands so this is going to be very quick
once the launch takes place a lot of
this is going to take place very quickly
with t-minus one and we should mention
good morning on bloomberg radio across
this nation and around
the world as well we'll give you the
image as much as we can
for bloomberg radio john i'm going to
give it over to you right now
as we really get finally down to the
final countdown for our audience
worldwide on bloomberg tv on bloomberg
radio for our audience on bloomberg
quick take the
mission is officially known as ns16d the
script is like something
out of a movie the richest man in the
world taking his brother
an 82 year old aviation icon and a
teenager
in the first human flight for blue
origin
it is 54 seconds away we're going to
hand over and listen into the command
center and the communications that take
place
we will not interrupt this we are 45
seconds out
[Music]
t minus 16 guidance internal
t-minus 10 9 8
seven six five four
command engine start two one
[Music]
find that
[Music]
[Music]
max cube
thirty thousand feet mach one
[Music]
so
different doesn't it gary this is
totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the uh middle of the
screen there
so far appears to be a nominal flight
all right coming up here on mikko main
engine cutoff that will be followed
shortly
by separation and at that point after
separation we're gonna
let the astronauts unbuckle and take in
the freedoms of zero g
there is miko main engine cut off
a beautiful shot down the new shepherd
rocket
look at that view
unreal
awaiting separation here
tom that vision that view never and here
you can start to see
and the speed here john is very very
important here this is not
orbital speed of 16 17 18 000
miles per hour but nevertheless thrust
to get up into space
well over a thousand miles per hour and
john the feet being added here
out to the 62-mile point we have passed
the point of the great
physics tension of the rocket in the
capsule
now waiting for that separation the
separation set to take place
in its entirety tom in about four
minutes and
30 seconds let's head back to emily
chang to walk us through
the next 10 minutes or so emily
all right john so look on the left hand
corner of your screen you see the
countdown clock the speed going down
when that gets to zero
that is the peak of the flight or apogee
as they say in the space industry
that is when they will be feeling those
uh
three to four minutes of weightlessness
and immediately after it hits zero the
speed starts going back up
as that crew capsule starts going back
down so there we are
at zero it's happened the capsule has
reached apogee
uh we imagine jeff bezos and his crew
are floating around
weightless inside that capsule right now
and that they are all feeling that
feeling that is
so coveted so rare that so few
humans have felt now you're going to see
the booster
coming down first so the lower portion
of your screen uh that will be the
booster descending back to earth
the crew capsule uh will descend after
that
john and tom an original image john
something i'm still not used to a
booster of a lighter
color in the capsule a brighter white
separating
apart as they come up to apogee and or i
should say come
coming down and john it's just an
absolutely original idea
no one thought of this mercury gemini
apollo just absolutely stunning tom and
i say it completes in about three
minutes time that's when the reusable
new shepherd booster
actually lands back down on earth and
then we get the experience the
experience that i think everyone who
goes in space
wants to see we know the cost of it for
virgin galactic tom it's about 200k 250k
we still don't know what this is going
to cost people if they would like to
follow
in the footsteps of jeff bezos and the
other three you know i got to admit
your one minute warning and you're on a
boeing flight over to lhr
and they tell you to get back in your
seat and buckle up this is a little more
important john
tom i've got to say this is a little bit
different to the transatlantic flight
that you and i would say
let's head back in and take a listen to
the events as they unfold
2 000 everybody is
first step
astronaut oliver
all of her status yet control
all of her palace perfect
guppy astronaut wally
copy astronaut bezos
[Applause]
[Music]
happy happy happy
copy
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for our first and you heard it
right there tom
astronaut bezos astronaut bezos
astronaut wally
astronaut damon and the returning of the
booster
the new shepherd booster returning back
to worth tom you can see the uh
coming back down to earth in about the
next 50 seconds that should be landing
so
after and radio it's just absolutely
extraordinary the flames now hitting on
the ground
the booster landing here i will have to
see where it is in the market it looks
pretty good right now
uh john let's let's let the smoke clear
before we go back to emily chang to be
sure yeah we
look at that it's the touchdown it's
just amazing it's phenomenal isn't it
it's like parallel parking on fifth
avenue
someone can do it absolutely you and i
can't do it let's confirm that right
here for our audience emily chang let's
bring it back into the conversation
the reusable new shepherd booster is
back on earth just walk us through
what's taking place
right now in the cap show the booster is
back on earth and as it was coming down
we heard that
sonic boom uh that we knew we would hear
if everything was going right it landed
safely the way it was supposed to
on the launch pad and it looks like it's
ready to go back up there
john the key is reusability bringing
that cost down
using these rockets over and over again
when that booster landed
we heard cheers from the crowd you've
got a lot of devoted people
employees who have been working here for
years watching this
and now we are watching that crew
capsule float on down those are the
drogue parachutes
the small parachutes that are used
especially
for vehicles at very very high velocity
they're designed to slow that capsule
down
as it speeds back towards earth and
these are the main parachutes
we're looking for full inflation here of
the main parachutes
that will slow the capsule down
as it approaches earth to bring it in
for a safe
landing the retro thrust system will
kick in
basically pushing out a cloud of air
below
the capsule and we expect it to land
in a cloud of desert dust look at that
it's getting closer and closer to the
ground just
15 1600 feet above the ground right now
you can imagine uh this is the
culmination of a live stream for jeff
bezos
um for wally funk as john you've been
talking about
an icon of aviation for mark bezos chef
bezos his brother
and for 18 year old oliver damon
uh there you see the crew capsule
descending
back to earth there are multiple
vehicles
on the ground in a grid pattern waiting
to zoom in
as soon as touchdown happens here emily
thank you that capsule tom keane
800 feet away it's just amazing to see
and of course the debate of land versus
sea 40 and 50 60 years ago and now
routinely done on let us listen in right
now
tom keane that looks successful to me i
don't know about you yeah we'll have to
see i
i believe it is successful amazing to me
john to see
the speed of which they seem to be
dropping and yet a very gentle landing
the hatch is due to open tom i
understand in the next 10 minutes or so
so we might have to wait a little while
to see who comes out of first the
pictures on your screen though for our
audience worldwide even listening on
bloomberg radio
the booster successfully touching down
the capsule
so far at least from what we can see
successfully launching down i believe
you can hear from jeff bezos
so let's take a listen copy first step
you have a very happy capcom here as
well
let's do a status check astronaut oliver
[Music]
copy after that demo
[Music]
go ahead and remain in your seats crew
member 7 is on their way
shortly you will hear the capsule
off-gassing
[Music]
everybody
[Laughter]
tom keane that looks like a successful
mission the astronauts checked in the
capsule
successfully returning to land that
hatch is due to open
in five or so minutes time uh the
capsule landing in the triangle of the
three parachutes laid out on the texas
desert or
the plains i guess i would call in the
light green scrub we say good morning on
bloomberg radio on television it's just
extraordinary
images of her return to space chad
anderson with us and a perfect time to
speak to him as blue origin has gathered
in celebration here i guess a flawless
mission is our first
take what is that signal from mr bezos
for mr musk
what is that signal for chad anderson i
mean they've been flawless since
since the beginning this is their 16th
flight they've all they've all
been flawless it's really great to see
we now officially have two suborbital
vehicles online that are taking humans
to space they're going to start doing so
regularly we have
spacex is taking nasa to the space
station
they have private missions lined up um
uh
you know later this year and we have
this is a new era in
human space flight why is nasa focused
on the efforts of mr musk and not on
those of mr bezos
well you know there's been a lot of
comparison between virgin galactic and
bezos and blue origin actually but the
ambitions of blue origin are much more
aligned with spacex
this is the first step in what they're
you know much larger ambition what does
mr musk learn from what we've seen this
morning
well i think you know he's congratu you
know he's wished them well and i'm sure
that he's he's happy to see this
this success happen it's happened he's
been a leader in
a lot of in a number of other categories
in tesla as well and he's happy to see
other electric vehicles coming online
i imagine he's got a similar sentiment
here um
you know one company does not make a
market and so
it's great to see the the increased
competition um driving further
innovation chad let's go to john furrow
as we see the
suv pull up to the capsule john two
vehicles approaching the capture one
individual running towards it tom just
waving at the astronauts inside they're
gonna open up that hatch
any moment from now tom any moment now
that hatch will be opened
so many of the memories here folks and
it's not only alan shepard being yanked
out of the ocean and gus grissom with
the capsule
going down into the ocean but it's
always an important mission now
i would assume john that the
weightlessness issue here of the shuttle
and the space
space station is not an issue when
you're up for 11 minutes i mean
what could go what can happen tell me it
certainly goes quickly
that's for sure i can see jeff bezos
inside reaching for his cowboy hat tom
i think that's going on right now as
they go to open up
that capsule we were taking bets on who
would exit first
tom who went in first i think jeff bezos
went in first so i'm pretty sure that mr
davis is going to be first down
do they come out and say i'm going to
disneyland i mean is that part of the i
don't think this is the super bowl tom
tom this is not the super bowl or the
way some people have delivered the
coverage of this
you'd expect it to be just as large it's
the what next of this tom
it's the what next to this this is the
first time for this company
what next craig let's go chad let's go
excuse me chad let's go to you quickly
here what is the next here that you
observe
i mean there's going to be more of these
flights they've got more lined up and
interestingly i mean it's gonna see it's
gonna be interesting to see where they
price this thing how many people are
going
we know that 7 500 people put in bids in
this auction
paying up to 28 million and there was
thousands of people who paid
you know any variation um and so it'll
be interesting to see where they end up
how virgin
responds and where blue origin goes next
john let's describe the scene for radio
here we've got a mic
up like they use for us and bloomberg
surveillance to make sure they
get it with tone but uh certainly a
different scene than anything i've seen
from nasa before john
i can count one two three four
individuals working on opening up that
capsule tom it's going to take a couple
of moments i think you can just about
see jeff bezos inside the capsule
waving around and giving the thumbs up
as we wait for that to open up i want to
bring in our colleague emily chang as we
await this moment
emily your thoughts on what's developed
in the past hour
john tom i mean we all have covered a
lot of stories
in our lives some of them are more
memorable than others i have to say this
is one
for the history books this is it's hard
not to get caught up in the energy and
the history
of this moment i mean it's one small
step
for jeff bezos perhaps one giant leap
for
uh space tourism and space exploration
and the vision that bezos has
articulated goes so far beyond
just people having a joy ride in space
he is talking
has talked about building this road to
space
the infrastructure that other
entrepreneurs can build on
he's talked about the fact that when he
started amazon um
you know he didn't have to start new
credit card systems
all of that was in place we had a mail
service that could deliver packages
to you space however is much more
undiscovered there is no infrastructure
he wants to build that infrastructure
so space entrepreneurs of the future can
build
a whole new generation of amazons out
there
and so it'll be interesting to see what
he has to say
as he steps off this flight and whether
or not the experience has changed him or
this vision
at all but it you know obviously this is
a suborbital flight
blue origin working on orbital flights
with the new glenn
that will be their next big project we
spoke to a lead designer who said
they're on track for that to be done
before the end of next year so who knows
jeff bezos could be up there again on an
orbital flight i believe that hatch door
is about to open
any moment now to see who comes out of
that capsule first the astronauts inside
are standing up standing up tom as we
await that door
to open perhaps in the next couple of
seconds they're going to descend
uh john and you know it's going to be a
great moment the stairs john frankly
look like the ones we have for the gulf
stream
the hatch door has opened at the couch
short time
exiting first is jeff bezos donning that
cowboy hat that
he's been wearing over the last week or
so tom after him
the first teenager the first human
flight the youngest ever
astronaut there tom and there you go tom
we keep talking about this moment
for the 82 year old aviation icon just
phenomenal
and his brother the last out of the
capsule
[Music]
[Applause]
gather around i would say 40 or 50
people in the texas desert fills you on
bloomberg radio it's being filmed it
will be part of their
propaganda if you will of the further
flights uh
to be had but what absolutely stuns me
john is this truly appears
to be absolute flawless execution we
again
hear a successful launch and landing
of the new shepard rocket and crew
capsule with our
first human flight crew there jeff bezos
mark bezos
oliver damon and wally funk
and their families there giving big hugs
all around what a moment so much emotion
from all of them the the elation did you
see
wally did you see wally when she came
out you know this
i told you she was just she was probably
going to do a summer you know
cartwheel as she came out of that
capsule what an
incredible incredible day a successful
mission
for an s16 for jeff bezos mark bezos
oliver damon and for wally fun kevin
chang to bring you back into the
conversation we keep talking about the
what
next of it what have we achieved today
that was not achieved two weekends ago
john i have to say from everything that
i could tell this was
an extremely successful mission this was
an opportunity
for jeff bezos to demonstrate blue
origins technology
to the world this is after a 21
year journey delays design changes
losing out on contracts government
contracts important government contracts
to spacex and up to this point spacex
has very much been
seen as the leader in this industry
spacex
has orbital rockets and is
already making trips to the
international space station and taking
astronauts there
this validates that blue origin has the
capability and
you wonder you have to assume certainly
that the folks at nasa are watching and
you wonder
uh if this changes something for nasa as
well we welcome you all to our coverage
of the markets opening john we have to
say within the markets and i want to go
to stem tenevec here
but john we have to say that as we have
had this launch we've had an adjustment
in the 10-year yield
to a lower yield that is worth noting as
we enter
a tuesday trading your 10-year yield
right now 113 on tens yields in about
five
six basis points for the broader market
your equity market around the opening
belt
positive just 0.15 on the open
of six points it's worth highlighting
tom
that for many many people they do not
like what they hear
and what they see around this story this
morning
as emily points out today that was a
successful mission for this company
there are many people though that would
like to see jeff bezos do a whole lot
more on planet earth
than what he's just done in the last one
hour yeah and one of the stark things
here folks is
like almost like an athletic locker room
they're breaking out the champagne for
those of you on bloomberg radio we can
always describe
a champagne moment tim steinovic that is
one of the stark differences here
between private enterprise you wouldn't
see that with a government nasa
effort as well i mean we're really
seeing a private enterprise tim
steinovic
where does it go from here yeah it's a
really good question it goes a lot of
different places for blue origin
they have two more of these flights
later this year they're shooting for
late september early october
unclear as we heard earlier how much
those are going to cost
the company has much much bigger
ambitions though
beyond space tourism jeff bezos has
talked about his vision for the future
he said in the past that if we can get a
trillion people
that's right a trillion people into the
solar system
that means we have a thousand einsteins
and a thousand mozarts the idea is that
the earth cannot sustain us
in order for materials in order for
energy
we have to explore further you know he
was asked earlier this week
earlier this week about the idea that
why focus on space
when we have so many problems here at
home and his answer was well
first of all i think we can do both at
the same time and
indeed in recent years he has increased
his investments with his own
philanthropy
but it is behind many other people of
immense wealth uh the other element of
that is that he said it's always
important for us to be exploring it's
always important for us to be
looking ahead and he says we can do both
of those things at the same time
i think it's right to sit on this
conversation tom you like me
i'm emily i'm sure as well and tim too
over the last hour
we've built up to this moment this
morning for blue origin a
momentous occasion truly historic but
for many people the frustration the
amount of messages that i've received in
the last 60 minutes criticizing
not just this coverage but the event
itself emily chang just to go over
the mission statement of blue origin
that you and i discussed a little bit
earlier this morning
i think it's worth sharing a couple of
lines with our audience blue origin
believes that in order to preserve earth
our home for our grandchildren's
grandchildren we must go to space to tap
its unlimited resources
and energy for jeff bezos and others
emily there is no distinction between
the work that needs to be done on earth
and the work that he thinks needs to be
done in space
absolutely and you know i think that
jeff bezos and blue origin
uh part of the opportunity here is for
them to explain that vision this has
been a very secretive company
for 21 years until today only one
journalist had
ever visited blue origin headquarters
today they're open to
the national press we are all here
watching this moment and wanting jeff
bezos to articulate
what that vision is why is he spending
so much of his money
exploring space for this 11 minute trip
up and down
how does that help us on earth and what
he has said
is i want to continue living on earth
this is the best planet
we love it here but we need to protect
it we're going to run out of energy
we need to go to space in order to mine
that energy from the sun
from the moon we don't need to go to
mars mars is inhospitable
we will not enjoy it there we don't want
to live on the moon either
we want to live on these space colonies
as he's described it
where it's like maui every day and you
can go back and forth
to earth whenever you want this is
hundreds of years out
but he imagines big industry in space
residential and light industry here on
earth
and blue origin he wants to be a huge
part of the infrastructure in building
out that space economy
the eyes of the world on the desert land
just outside of van horn
west texas right now 8 37 local time 9
37 in new york tom so allow me to check
in on the markets just briefly
seven minutes into the session it has
been a huge 24 hours for this market
equities up by a third of one percent
with your bounce back
this is what it looks like as follows on
the s p 500
advancing just a little bit 12 13 points
higher but once again tom
it's the bond market that gets your
attention and maybe the bond market
pedals in comparison to what we've seen
in the last hour or so but your 10 year
right now
just south of 114 tom down five basis
points on the day i'm going to brag for
the 108th mayor of new york and for
thomas secundo when they did their
innovation of inventing the bloomberg
terminal john
it was absolutely original that you
could go from what was called a monroe
trader
out to convexity and duration math and
then to immediate log
analysis of charts i can tell you john
it was just like what you're watching
with mr bezos
on the texas desert the 10-year yield
right now john
is a textbook chart of a lower
highs on yield it has been one two three
and on and on back
over the last 15 days or so
it is stunning to see price up and yield
down to a 1.1392
john we have to begin to be on the 0.99
watch
unbelievable for our audience worldwide
on bloomberg tv and radio and of course
for our audience on bloomberg quick take
the coverage continues with tom keane
myself jonathan ferro
alongside our good friends and
colleagues emily chang and tim stenovic
we'll continue to cover the markets but
also this event
tom i talked about the late 90s and
amazon are the kind of people that threw
mud at that company in its valuation why
would this company be valued
what it's valued when it's just an
online bookseller without the vision of
what this could become
and i'm conscious of that particular
moment in the late 90s and conditioned
by it because i do not want that clip to
play in 20 years time of me
repeating that same error throwing mud
at a mission that's taken place in the
last hour
without any imagination on what this
momentum can develop what this
moment can develop into yes amazon had a
crazy valuation but it became something
so much bigger
than just an online bookseller and you
wonder if jeff basil can repeat the act
tom
with blue origin well it's a repeat the
act but it's a strategic plan to move
forward and again they have that plan
in shepherd a single engine rocket which
will be put on top of a larger rocket
and that will be called glenn chad
anderson knows this with space capital
and continues with this patient this
morning at this historic moment
what's after glenn do they make does
jeff bezos
want to go to the moon he does he's he's
working with a consortium of he's
he's partnered up with a few of the
incumbents and is was competing for a
contract that he lost out on to
musk and spacex and they've fought
against that
and it looks like they're going to press
ahead spacex was the only one that put
in a bid that was affordable
freemason you're very good at this frame
for this now
china doing a matt damon equivalency on
mars
we're out on mars with a helicopter that
goes around
there's government interest there's
international interest there's private
billionaire interest as well
how do they dovetail together in 2031.
well this is how so many new markets
and nascent markets develop the
government is an early investor in the
technology risk
um and in the r d and that's what we've
seen over the last 50 or 60 years in
space
and then with the retirement of the
space shuttle we were basically saying
this has become
routine getting to orbit and it's become
too expensive
and in order to keep doing this we need
to work with commercial partners
and that's what you know spacex 10 years
ago was able to break through kind of
the deadlock
of the defense contractors who kind of
had a
a tight grip on this market and they've
lowered the prices i mean they are
allowing nasa to do more with their
limited budget
resupplying the space station taking
astronauts the space station maintaining
station
and also going out to deeper space
missions and exploring exploring the
solar system let's get some final
thoughts from our colleagues
on the ground emily chang i want to come
to you first please
john you were asking about lunar
ambitions and what's so fascinating
about this entire design process that
has of course taken place over 21 years
here at blue origin is they have built
uh their future
ambition going out hundreds of years
into the design
of the rocket that jeff bezos sat on
today
the rocket is powered by hydrogen and
oxygen a very
simple mixture and on the moon what do
you find
but water hydrogen and oxygen so the
idea is that once a
rocket presumably lands on a moon a
blue origin rocket they can turn what's
on the moon
into rocket fuel to get that rocket back
to earth to power it through
the space economy and you know what i
would say is
what we have witnessed today is nothing
short of extraordinary sure i know there
are people out there
uh who are unhappy with how jeff bezos
is spending his time but this is an
incredible fleet the birth of private
space
industry the idea that we don't have to
rely on governments
to get to space that private citizens
can go there
if they want to on their own craft so
this up and down sub-orbital mission
this is just the tip
of a very long journey it's orbital
missions next perhaps lunar missions
after that all building towards this
future space
ecosystem that jeff bezos has envisioned
emily i know you've got to run
what have you got to run to you've got
to go get an interview with jeff bezos
is that right
i i've got to go i have a very important
conversation and we're going to get it
back to you as fast as we possibly i'm
looking forward to that emily you run
run away
it's been great to catch up thanks for
your help this morning tim stenovick
you've had problems with the audio
all morning i'm going to take another
shot at this and give you a final word
timmy there
i'm here and all is good here in van
horn you know
when the new shepard went up it was
silent here in van horn i
was able to see the trail left by the uh
by the rocket motor as it uh exceeded uh
hundreds of thousands of feet one thing
that i have been thinking a lot about
though is
is what comes next and we know what
comes next for blue origin but there's a
lot that we don't know about what comes
next i mean think about where we were 60
years ago
after shepard's journey into space
we didn't imagine that where we'd be
sitting we'd be able to
do satellite technology that would allow
me to
be talking to you guys or even
potentially imagine
that we could do uh global positioning
systems so
easily or use global positioning systems
to monitor climate change or what elon
musk is doing
uh with starlink delivering internet to
areas all over the world
the fact is is even though these
billionaires these entrepreneurs they do
have these grand visions
the idea of what we could be seeing in
the next 10 20 years
we don't even know yet what that looks
like
tim steinovic thank you so much greatly
appreciate it this morning
from van horn texas right now as we move
forward and again this with an equity
left in the market up 228 points and
the bond market with those lower yields
we continue with one final discussion
here
uh on our moment in space and that is
the engineering of our many space
programs daniel wood
is expert at this director of space
enabled research group
at mit media lab who dovetails a lot of
social efforts and social policy
into grunt engineering and i say that
danielle with immense
immense respect there's that see
danielle
in apollo 13 where they're going to die
and the three engineers are in mission
control and they got the canister and
they're going to purify the oxygen
or the astronauts are going to die and
they all pull out and sync
their khuful nasser slide rules we are
so far removed from the slide rules
of a busted apollo mission what is the
technology
forward that we will see from this
private enterprise
it's wonderful to celebrate today i'm so
happy for wally funk
and for somebody like her who's had such
a long road to this
road to space and we can think about the
technology by asking
you know what has been the road for all
the companies i was
in college watching the ansari x prize i
want to appreciate
anish ansari who helped fund some of the
early investments by private companies
trying to demonstrate the ability to put
a human into space through a suborbital
mission several times in a row and what
we're seeing today you know with
multiple launches by private companies
is part of this long journey there's
also been a great coordination between
government
and private sector i used to work for
nasa and nasa has within its
congressional mandate something called
the space act agreement capability
meaning they can make agreements with
organizations that are private sector
organizations
to share engineering knowledge and
experience on space flight
professor wood you were a kennedy center
canaan i'm sorry it's cape canaveral
professor just so you know
for some of us that are of a certain age
you were an intern there
and i'm sure in your orlando and your
central florida
you were grilled why are we doing this
explain
now why are we doing this in 2021
everyone on earth is benefiting from the
investments that governments
and the private sector are making in
space i travel all over the world
and i engage with leaders of countries
in africa latin america the caribbean
southeast asia countries on every
continent are investing in space
infrastructure
and are looking for ways for private
companies to play a role in the space
ecosystem
because face brings us many benefits
through observing the environment
understanding responding to climate
change managing our fragile coastlines
and also thinking about providing
services but even human space flight
and microgravity research helps us
transfer benefits from space back to
earth
we understand better how to recycle
water how to recycle air and make
ecosystems that are clean whether
artificial but also on earth
and we also understand better how our
bodies and plants and animals respond
in an environment like microgravity
which explains the fundamental physics
better
there's also the inspiration side i am
running a program at mit called zero
robotics
and we're inviting middle school
students from around the country to
learn about space robotics and how to
code
and one day we hope to do this with the
collaboration of the space station
and expose them uh to the space station
which has been done before in the past
and so
these opportunities inspire the next
generation of leaders as well the great
fear here
is that will be a success for the elites
as you well know we have two americas
how do we translate technological
innovation
how do we translate as brynjolson and
mcafee talk about the race against the
machine
how do we translate this technology over
to the have nots
a technological have-nots of america
i spend a lot of my time thinking about
how we can do engineering design in a
way that's equitable
advances environmental sustainability
and economic justice
this means first asking who's involved
and showing that we have increased
diversity and access to technology
it also means designing these space
systems in a way that directly serves
the needs of those who've experienced
environmental injustice or long-term
discrimination
it also means listening to groups like
indigenous communities that have
concerns cultural questions about what
humans do in space for example
thinking of the moon as a sacred place
there's a lot of ways we can use space
technology
to provide services like disaster
response for example and we can also
then listen to those who usually don't
have a strong a chance to give their
view on what we do in space
because we're about to make some key
decisions as a human race and how we
treat the space environment and i think
we need more voices involved in this
going forward
danielle just a final word from you you
mentioned the public private
partnerships and i think it's spot on to
point that out
but for many of these efforts they're
increasingly privatized and the gains
will be shared with
the shareholders and i wonder your
thoughts on that as we move away from
strictly a government effort
towards something much more highly
privatized
i think it's so important that we
continue to see uh government
infrastructure allowing services like
research opportunities for universities
like internationally shared climate data
that's important for everyone around the
world
i hope that that becomes a private sorry
a public
service that continues over years to
come there will also be
private activities that kind of build on
the government infrastructure i think it
remains to
be seen whether that's going to be only
open to the elite it is possible for
private companies to consider how they
can have business models
that provide further openness to those
who have less access or less ability to
pay
but this is a choice that they need to
make and i hope they do make it
professor wood thank you so much for
joining us with the mit media
lab daniel wood this morning john i
think we've got to do a market check we
always need to do that with green on the
screen
and we can use all the space innovation
john to say
once again i looked for a window of
opportunity
and you missed it thank you 4287 on the
s p we bounced back seven tenths of one
percent after the choppiness we've seen
in the last 24 hours here's one for you
though tom
take a look at space take a look at
virgin galactic and how it's trading
this morning
stand by 7.6 in early trading
now the leaders of these companies when
they're asked about the competition they
don't want to talk about the competition
they believe this is a joint effort
to make steps and progress where we
haven't made any progress for the last
couple of decades
i think investors do see it slightly
differently a successful mission
for blue origin and virgin galactic
south of 30 at 29.90 and down 8
tom it's interesting to see chad
anderson with us with a final thought
here he has been more than patient space
capitals managing
a partner of the dovetail of all of this
innovation
the nasa that we used to know and maybe
the nasa that's still there
with where we're moving forward and you
know we've talked about the next steps
of these people but to john's point does
private enterprise and private
competition
get in the way of space success
absolutely not it's driving it forward
we started off in a place where we had
never been to space then we launched a
satellite then we launched a human and
then we landed on the moon and we've
been regressing ever since and it's only
thanks to private efforts
that we are now accelerating um back
into
so what does nasa think of this event
today i think they think very highly of
this event and then they're very happy
to see the success
again they're benefiting from this they
are
going to now be able to rely on low-cost
innovative partners leveraging
reusability
and enabling them to do more with their
limited budgets
i mean this this hits on a few different
notes one the inspiration front
um two the competition it's driving
innovation forward and three
we wouldn't be we wouldn't have the
capability that we have today without
space technology these guys in texas
cowboy hats teach anybody at jpl
anything i'm serious i mean or it might
not not the media lab at mit but mit
aeronautics
the legacy of harold edgerton and the
rest of it can they teach the pros
anything
that's a great question and my only good
one today so you better go with it
100 yes and they learn from each other
it's a symbiotic relationship so nasa
has a lot of heritage and a lot of great
you know embedded expertise they've been
there and they've done that the private
sector is challenging a lot of the
embedded
assumptions and doing things in new ways
allowing them to do things more
effectively
and more cost effectively chad just
quickly investable opportunities right
now let's close right there
is this a single night the name
opportunity or do you want to play the
industry
as a whole we've gone from a very
limited market
uh 10 years ago handful of defense
contractors on one side and the
government on the other
there has now been 200 billion dollars
invested in over 1500 unique space
companies
over the last 10 years this is a massive
market opportunity
cuts across the infrastructure the
distribution and the applications of
that satellite data
in space technology stacks such as gps
geospatial intelligence and
communications this is a massive
market opportunity that we're just on
the forefront of
i love asking that question and seeing
an investor tom lean in just lead in
and give the pitch give the pitch chad
anderson there with the pitch
space capital managing partner chad
thank you for being with us through the
last couple of hours and as we wrap up
our coverage
worth pointing out that there will be a
news conference following the blue
origin space flight the news conference
taking place with jeff bezos coming up
at about 11
eastern time on bloomberg television and
on bloomberg radio and i'm sure our
colleagues over at bloomberg quick take
will be carrying that as well tom before
we go we've talked about the degree of
criticism we've had we talked about the
degree of support
that we've had let me allow the words of
a bloomberg terminal subscriber to speak
just for a moment this got sent in
moments ago
and i'd like to share it with our
audience bezos and musk are using their
own money
to do things with the us government has
not made a lot of progress on in the
last 20 to 40 years
this individual goes on to say i grew up
watching a moon landing as a young child
the space shuttle launched in florida
when in high school and have a signed
picture from apollo 15
john irwin on my wall people saying they
should do more on earth
ignores the great advances in technology
that pushing into space help drive
and if nothing cows sparking the
imagination of the world's youth
to try things that haven't been done
before now if we say something has been
successful today
tom just as far as that statement is
concerned i think the effort towards
that
i think we've seen a success this
morning well as mr bezos said i don't
need to say it mr bezos can say it we
can do both and that's always been
the rationalization and they are trying
to do both for our audience worldwide on
bloomberg television on bloomberg radio
on bloomberg quick take that does it for
our coverage right here i want to turn
to the price section and get you up to
speed
on what's going on in this month there
you go back to the board we're going to
go
tell them come on oh it's your show i
forgot excuse me my show's like a minute
a long time i'm over